back here on the show former Browns and
Eagles executive to use the phrase I
think that we've seen on come TV he
knows a thing or two cuz he's seen a
thing or two back here on the program
how are you Joe I think today is the key
word and the statement you just read so
I don't even know where to start here
let's let's just start I guess with what
you thought of when you saw mike Mayock
statement yesterday Joe banner well I
had the mixture of sympathy I had rise
in my own personal blood pressure having
lived through a somewhat similar
situation and I had a reaction like how
can you be surprised so I had all three
at once somebody you know they you know
people don't change their stripes and we
have an incredibly talented player who's
extremely high maintenance and that's
who he is and that's he's gonna be and
they shouldn't be surprised so what do
you think the options are
walk me through you know the options if
in fact Antonio Brown decides that he's
all out because of a helmet issue that
clearly it's it's difficult to see a way
out of here Joe what happens well they
can cut him I mean I haven't seen a
player contract that ever doesn't
require the player to report and
practice and I'm sure his contract
requires that and if he doesn't do that
they have the right to cut him and they
can claim that he was in default of the
contract and his guarantees are voided
I'm sure there'd be a grievance although
at least on the surface it looks like
the Raiders would have a pretty good
case they can give them what they call a
five day letter which requires them to
kind of report and kind of no more
nonsense or the consequences that I just
mentioned are even worse because he
basically has to sit out for the season
if he's not there in five days and
although he's there today you know this
could be you know at least over in terms
of us coming and leaving or not we don't
really know or they could just say you
know what we knew what we would get I
know we think the talent is worth and
we're going to put up with it but they
should not have any illusion that
his reporting means everything's fine
and now let's just get back to football
it's just not the way it goes well I
sell I was talking earlier Joe that you
know what if week one through three he's
got 12 catches for 200 yards in one
touchdown don't you think he'd blame the
helmet as much as the scheme potentially
I mean I don't want to be negative here
but I try to be realistic right ya know
we're not seeing somebody who's kind of
owning it so to speak you know I know
drew is kind of belittling this
perspective but there are twenty two
hundred plus football players who camp
right now wearing allowed helmets he
didn't have to leave as you just said he
could have been there yesterday he could
have been trying a different helmet on
the sideline he could have been there
last week you know it's just kind of you
know the petulance is really what it is
he was just you know wasn't happy with
the outcome and so he took his ball and
went home I mean you you can't do that
when you play professional football
you're under contract you get paid a lot
of money and most importantly you have a
coaching staff of probably 20 25 people
and eighty nine players that are
counting on you you you have to find a
different way to manage your upsetness
and to think that the scenario you
described or any other won't kind of set
him off is probably unrealistic so you
know my worry is one of the lessons I
learned in 20 years in the league and
especially in some of these situations
is you you must mean what you say and
say what you mean
so what Mark said he's either all-in or
he's not what what does that mean what
is he going to do because if Antonio
Bryant or perfect or acog Neto some of
the other challenging players that they
signed this up cease and realize that
they're all talk and if you get enough
talent they'll put up basically anything
that's going to turn into a crazy place
to try to be a head coach and get
everybody on the same page and be
successful so you know I don't know what
he meant like what was he going to do is
he gonna cut him I don't believe that I
really go and I don't think they're
sending him a five-day letter or
anything out
but fortunately he came back in for the
moment so they didn't get there I'm
gonna use the word Bluff called so to
speak it was a dangerous position
because he could have been exposed that
somebody who doesn't mean what he says
and then once that happened players will
take advantage of the situation
Joe Banner former Eagles president
Browns front office executive here on
the Rich Eisen show when you said maybe
did you get any flashbacks watching Drew
Rosenhaus respond about a player not in
camp with a lot of drama surrounding it
Joe to that strike you take you back a
days yesterday yeah well I lived through
T ough and watch drew in a similar
position was most interesting to me
about drew and where I really draw an
analogy when we were going through we
did with tio and we watched drew on TV
we could actually tell that he wasn't
sure what the player was going to do
next you knew what he was advising him
to do you know what he knew what made
sense to do but you could tell he didn't
completely have control of the player
and when I started talking today and he
was talking kind of and I don't think
this is gonna go on long and I can't
promise but I'm pretty sure he'll be
there but when you start using those
pretty sure I think language about your
own client you're telling people they
you may know what's right and we can
probably tell what you're advising him
but you have no real idea if he's gonna
do what you think he should do and you
know from a team's perspective that's
scary you hope you got some people in
the players here at a moment like this
that are talking some sense to him and
you know will let what is that
everybody's best interest happen but I
could tell it was kind of himself
worried about where this is headed and
probably very rude to me is there today
Joe banner / former Eagles president
here on the Rich Eisen show I mean in
terms of what you were talking about
about tio it's when Andy Reid and I got
you and everybody together got together
and told tio to leave camp and he wound
up doing sit-ups on the front lawn I
remember we broke in live on NFL Network
we were just a baby of a network back
then and we our minds were blown by it
I'm wondering what what insight you have
on the decision-making that maybe the
Raiders are going after have you
mentioned a bluff if you will of being
all out with with Antonia Brown about
the issues of putting a foot down with a
player and the deliberations that go
down for that using your your T ough
example with churros and houses as I
guess a guide yeah who is he suggested
today we were talking all this time we
just weren't agreeing and as I said it
was obvious he didn't have control over
the players so a lot of led up to that
we had a meeting at the beginning of
[ __ ] with camp with Drew and tio and
myself and Andy it was intended to be a
kind of clear the air meeting but it
didn't actually go that way you know you
may recall we had a series of interviews
at tio at Don where he had said things
about donovan mcnabb that you know we
weren't okay with Don over wasn't okay
with his teammates weren't okay with
which is actually the straw that broke
the camel's back he did kind of another
interview after having agreed privately
that he would not say anything more
publicly that would be divisive in the
relationship between him and Donovan and
Donovan and the team and you know he did
it interview that you know we had no
idea was coming and then just came out
and we basically had my ultimatum you'd
have to apologize you really have to
meet at this sudden that I can do this
again I have to leave some and he left
and that was the end of his Eagles
career he was suspended for the last six
games of the year he had a grievance
we actually prevailed and agreements he
lost in signing bonus money and an
income that was doing that year and then
we moved on but it was damage was left
behind you know from the the situation
and players do feel the need to kind of
take aside and at the same time they're
looking out for themselves and you know
a player like Antonio Brown player like
tio and they're just so talented they
help lift the whole team and so
everybody feels like they're let down
when everyone they're not there but my
biggest lesson is what I said earlier
don't get into a mode where making
threats or talking tough unless you've
agreed privately that you're going to
back it up because if they see some
wiggle room they will take it so last
one on this Joe you mentioned forfeiture
language and cap hits
whatever what would it be I mean you
said there was agreed there would be a
grievance case that the Raiders could
win again we are extrapolating this out
to the worst case scenario that may not
happen because Browns back in camp or
with the team the fact that Browns with
the with the team might not mean that
he's gotten over the helmet issue so
let's just use this as an exercise for
all of the fans of the show to to take
in what do you mean by forfeiture
language and and and the money that
would be cost so the players have and
I've never seen a country that didn't
include this very basic obligations in
order to earn their pay or maintain
guarantees on future money and they
start with things as simple as the
player must report and the player must
practice and play is healthy which is
why I think we still hear Dru talking a
little bit about the food injury because
he's probably smart enough to realize
that he may need to use that if they do
get to this point and you know they
could cut him you know him nothing they
could claim that he has defaulted on the
guarantee language so they keep him and
they pay it as they go but he no longer
has any guarantees
remember tio we will probably into the
contracts we had already paid him so we
were actually positioned we could
recover part of what we paid I doubt
that would be applicable in this
situation but he's not he's risking all
of the money that he has coming to him
in the future contract and at a minimum
he's risking all of the guarantees on
that money I mean if I was the Raiders I
would certainly be arguing that you have
no longer got this guaranteed money I
could go through a whole legal process
file it with the league give the player
warnings this whole series of steps you
have to follow so that if he continued
to act up even if he was in camp I no
longer have any guarantee obligations
which frankly turns the leverage from
the player back to the team so that you
can now make demands once he's got 31
Galentine million dollars and you have
no way out of that a player can act very
badly and there's not a whole lot you
can do about it if he doesn't have those
guarantees which I would argue he's
already taken action that from which the
Raiders could at least get out of the
guarantee
then the team has quite a bit of
leverage and the amount of money that
they owe him in the risky sticky that he
could see none of it so the fact that
he's in there I suspect they won't want
to rock the boat they won't want to make
an issue of this because you know when
you get a player around who you wearing
what they're gonna do next you try not
to provoke them but they may look back
and regret that next week or a month
into the season depending upon what's
happening last one for you Joe banner
before I let you go oh you got any sense
of what's going on with the Cowboys and
Zeke and DAC right now I mean less than
three weeks to to go now until the
Giants show up in the Jones Mahal for
week one what do you think but then he
did follow up by saying that that Tony
Pollard would be a great complement for
Zeke when Zeke comes back he did say
that after all the laughter subsided
uh-uh he was smart enough to realize
that he better make sure it was obvious
he was joking all right I think he gets
done you know I think Zach gets done I
said to see the last time we spoke the
only way dak doesn't get done if he's
really decided he wants to be the next
Kirk Cousins play a year take a couple
of tags take the risk on his performance
and his and his health and then try to
be a young quarterback and really hit
the mark and just see what the value
would be in this case that would make me
a little bit nervous you know I think
you better make sure you have a talented
player that's likely to have a decent
amount of demand before you take that
chance and I like Prescott but I'm not
sure he's quite at that level maybe a
little bit better to take the shorter
thing at this point but we don't really
know exactly what he's asking for what
they're offering I wouldn't do that if I
didn't feel like it's at least in the
range of fair but I still think they get
these deals done that this is their
history their patient when they need to
get a deal done they get them done and I
think we'll see both those guys happy
here in the next about three weeks Joe
thanks for the time really appreciate it
always enjoy our chats we'll chat again
soon my pleasure take it easy right back
atcha at Joe Banner thirteen on Twitter
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR Live or download the Rich Eisen
show